hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in being in time martin heidegger has
introduced this this term design for
essentially human being and he tells us
that we need to carry out an existential
analysis of design a little bit later
he's going to talk in terms of
interpretation and that becomes a very
important term and and concept in this
work
why is interpretation so central design
is the being that can be concerned about
its own being but it's also the being
that understands other beings and
understands the being of being that may
be a little bit unclear at this point
but you know the analysis try all again
in being in time Martin Heidegger takes
the fundamental inquiry that the entire
work is concerned with to be at least in
part an existential analysis of design
let's try one more time in being in time
one of the fundamental tasks that the
entire book is attempting to carry out
is an existential analysis of design and
this is supposed to allow us to approach
what Heidegger calls the question of
being that has been up until this point
largely ignored or misunderstood and to
reappropriation a not entirely novel but
but certainly a region airy way getting
back to the the source taking away a lot
of the d'etre test that blocks our view
of it Heidegger is going to talk about
this in terms of interpretation this is
a very important term running throughout
the whole of the work design human being
is by its very
being interpretive and what does that
mean when we say interpretive a lot of
times people think that interpretation
means there's something objective fixed
and then you just have your own
subjective interpretation of it
Heidegger is not working with that sort
of concept the interpretation is in many
respects more creative or collaborative
even when it's completely deforming
something it is still carrying out that
that agency that involves us and this is
part of the way in which we
distinctively are as human beings
Heidegger in the beginning of section 5
will talk about design the human being
as an tically not only what is near or
even nearest we ourselves he says are in
each of us we are design right so Diane
is human being and he talks about this
in terms of it being on tically dealing
with the the factual ality the the you
know what presents itself to us but if
we if we start to go to the very
structures of being and of our being we
look at it ontological II he says for
this reason design is ontologically what
is farthest removed and he says it
belongs to its most proper being to have
an understanding of this being so we
always have some conception of what we
are and indeed it goes beyond just you
know a solipsistic what I am and extends
to what it is that that human being in
general yes no it could be completely
mistaken understanding although it's
actually impossible for it to be
completely mistaken from a Haida garyun
perspective but we always have some sort
of interpretation going on so he says we
have an understanding of this being and
we sustain a certain interpretation of
it and he says this does not mean that
the most readily available pre
ontological before we carry out this
inquiry interpretation of its own
could be adopted as an adequate
guideline why can't we adopt that as an
adequate guideline because if we do we
are you might say skewing the inquiry
from the beginning we're putting out a
certain kind of blinder or filter we
want to try to carry out an
interpretation that goes to the
realities or things themselves as
phenomenology had had taken as its
slogan so design human being is the
being that understands being and beings
understands not in the sense of
comprehensively gets everything
completely right but has some sort of
understanding has something that it's
working with and it understands its own
being the goal here is in part as
Heidegger is going to say a little bit
later is that we must choose a manner of
access and interpretation so that this
being can show itself to itself on its
own terms so we can do so in a you know
more adequate way now Heidegger says we
already have a number of candidates for
interpretations of design of human being
and he tells us here we go not only does
an understanding of being belonging to
design this this understanding also
develops or decays according to the
actual manner of being of design at any
given time so the understanding can get
get greater and can get lesser then he
goes on and he gives us a list of
different disciplines
he says philosophical psychology
anthropology ethics politics poetry
biography and historiography pursue in
different ways and to varying extents so
each of them is doing its own thing now
notice what he says here the behavior
faculties powers possibilities and
destinies of design each of these
or bodies of work or human activities
modes of inquiry is in fact revealing to
us something that does belong to design
but it's not revealing to us the
entirety of it and there's a danger in
taking this as the starting point any of
these disciplines of prejudicing the
inquiry from the very beginning so he
goes on and he says the question remains
whether these interpretations were
carried out in as original an
existential manner as their existential
meaning from the possibilities of design
originality perhaps merited now he's
actually giving a compliment there he's
saying each of these is important each
of these does in fact reveal to us
possibilities of design they just simply
don't reveal to us all of them and they
don't go deep enough so let's think
about what each of these would would
include and what we might also add to
the list today
philosophical psychology many people
don't really know this but psychology
was originally a discipline within
philosophy had to do with the soul the
poo hey all right and then it extended
to dealing with you know thoughts and
emotions in the relations between them
and how we are formed by our environment
or formed by other determinants and what
happens to us when we you know undergo a
trauma or you know what is normal human
development all of that actually fits in
the philosophical psychology you know
much of the the good psychology that's
out there that that is aware of its own
origins and sometimes its own
limitations tends to be philosophical
anthropology now when you hear the word
anthropology you may have different
things in mind you may be thinking for
example about people engaging in
archaeological investigation or talking
about various bones and measuring them
and trying to figure out you know what
the missing link between these things is
or going out and doing ethnographic
studies in various cultures there's a
number of different anthropology
at this point all connected together in
the fact that they are a study of human
being
ethics you might not think of ethics as
actually being a mode of disclosure of
design but that's the way Heidegger
conceives of it
it is indeed once we adopt ethical
perspectives and start to raise ethical
concerns we are thinking we are
interpreting within the horizon right
same thing with politics and notice that
he's treating them in in different ways
and and historically we have often
distinguished these to poetry now
doesn't that seem like a strange
addition to this list and yet why do
people read poems what do they get out
of it is it to you know go to poetry
slams and make a big stir and you know
make a political statement or something
like that poetry
Heidegger thinks has a great capacity to
reveal to us beings in a very different
light he's particularly interested in
people like who they're in right but you
know at the time that he's writing this
one of the great poets of the 20th
century
you know rainer maria rilke most of his
stuff is actually out there and
available biography
why is biography a way of revealing to
us an interpretation of design isn't it
just about that one person there well
it's about a person in his or her milieu
in engagement with other persons within
a kind of history so it reveals to us
something more than just a person in
isolation this is why Plutarch's
parallel lives can still be relevant to
us today historiography why not just
history there why historiography the
discipline that is you might say at a
slightly higher meta level where history
is concerned with how indeed history is
carried out is it being done in a
more objective way is it focusing on the
culture of the everyday person as
opposed to the battles of the Lord's how
do we know that historical documents
they actually give us something like an
unvarnished interpretation of of things
right all of that fits in there all of
these are ways of interpreting the world
and design in relation to it Heidegger
says we have to put all of those aside
for the time being what then do we take
as our starting point so he says the
problem of gaining and securing the kind
of access that leads to that design is
is really crucial expressed negatively
no arbitrary idea of being in reality no
matter how self-evident it is maybe
brought to bear on this being in a
dogmatically constructed way no
categories prescribed by such ideas may
be forced on design without ontological
deliberation so what can we do that well
Heidegger talks here about the everyday
and the average right he says the matter
of access and interpretation has to be
chosen it has to be selected in such a
way that this being can show itself on
its own terms of passage we've brought
up before so he says this manner should
show that being as it is initially and
for the most part in what he calls its
average everydayness so we need to look
at how people do in fact live experience
interact with the world understand each
other and the world so he says not
arbitrary and accidental structures but
essential ones are to be demonstrated in
this everydayness he goes on and says
structures that remain determinate in
every mode of factual design so you know
this is something that should in theory
at least stretch back and encompass
pretty much all of humanity and human
experience not to say that every single
experience is exactly like what
Heidegger sketching out but these
structures these ontological structures
that the existential analysis of design
are going to be revealing to us about
Danis can be found he would say within
every cultural situation does that mean
that we simply begin by being in the
world and looking around and seeing you
know writing little memoirs about what
our day is like no we have to go deeper
we have to follow a leading clue and
that leading clue is what he calls
temporality sightly kite being in time
or being you might say of time and with
time so he goes on and he says the
meaning of the being of that being that
we called Ossie and proves to be
temporalities we repeat our
interpretation of these structures of
design this time as modes of temporality
so much of this work is actually going
to be investigating what time and
temporality are for us how we interpret
time and thereby how we interpret being
and how we interpret ourselves he goes
on and he says design is in such a way
that by being it understands something
like being we must show that time is
that from which design tacitly
understands and interpret something like
being at all so it's not as if you have
being first and after that time no you
only get being by having time he goes on
a little bit more and in that that
section and he says time has long served
as the ontological and then he takes it
back he's there's no no on tick
criterion for naively distinguishing
different regions of being for carrying
out regional ontology Zoar attempting a
total ontology temporal beings are
separated from a temporal beings right
what are temporal beings natural
processes historical events beings like
you and I separated from a temporal
being spatial and numerical
relationships we are he says were
accustomed to distinguishing the
timeless meaning of propositions from
the ten
Perle course of propositional statements
for example he doesn't use this it is
day right now actually true at the time
that I'm filming this who knows what it
is at the time that you're watching this
and it's not true if you're on the other
side of the world isn't and yet the
phrase it is day right now has a meaning
separable from the current time bound
meaning doesn't it so we make these
sorts of distinctions how is it that we
do this Heidegger says that what we're
going to do is he says we must show on
the basis of the question of the meaning
of being that and in what way the
central range of problems of all
ontology is rooted in the phenomenon of
time correctly viewed and correctly
explained so this means that all of this
must be interpreted or rather
reinterpreted in terms of an adequately
developed understanding of temporality
that is one of the main goals of
Heidegger's work here in being in time
you